nunca se daño tener más práctica así es
que aquí tenemos el ejercicio número 5
del capítulo de instrucción normal del
libro dsk 12 puntos sobre estadística de
ap nos plantean las calificaciones del
examen de estadística de ap del 2007 no
se distribuyó normalmente con media de
2.8 y desviación estándar de 1.34 aquí
hacen referencia a una nota que yo no
copie y pegue cuál es el puntaje z
aproximado y recuerda el puntaje z es un
valor que nos indica a cuántas
desviaciones estándar con respecto a la
media se encuentra y que corresponde a
una calificación el examen de 5 este es
un problema directa porque lo que
tenemos que calcular es a cuántas
desviaciones estándar se encuentra con
respecto a la media el valor de 5 así es
que lo que tenemos que calcular es 5
tenemos que hacer la resta de 5 menos
2.8 la media es 2.8 voy a precisar lo
medio es igual a 2.8 nos dieron ese
valor media 2.8 no tuvimos que
calcularlo entonces 5 menos 2.8 nos da 2
punto 2 así que estamos a 2.2 arriba de
la media y si queremos eso en términos
de la desviación estándar dividimos esto
en t 1.34 2.2 / 1.34 esto nos da igual
sacamos la calculadora entonces es 2.2 /
1.34 nos da igual a 1.64 esto es igual a
1.64 que la respuesta del inciso c esto
fue bastante directo simplemente vimos
que tan lejos está de la media una
calificación de 5 que esperemos que sea
la que tú saques en el próximo examen de
estadística de la p lo divides entre la
desviación estándar para establecer
cuántas desviaciones arriba de la media
es una calificación de 5 lo cual nos dio
1.64 esta pregunta pudiera ser un poco
capciosa sobre todo si estás tentado a
escoger el inciso que dice un puntaje z
no se puede calcular pues la
distribución no es normal y podrías
estar tentado a escoger esta opción
porque hemos estado usando los puntajes
z en el contexto de la distribución
normal pero un puntaje zetas
significa cuántas desviaciones estándar
estás alejado con respecto a la media se
puede aplicar para cualquier
distribución de la cual puedas calcular
la media y la desviación estándar que no
es la respuesta correcta un puntaje z lo
puedes calcular para cualquier
distribución aunque no sea normal ser la
respuesta correcta qué bueno que surgió
esto para aclarar este punto creo que
haré dos problemas en este vídeo porque
ese primero fue muy corto si es que
problema número seis las estructuras de
los alumnos de quinto año en los eeuu
tiene una distribución que es
aproximadamente normal lo cual es bueno
saberlo con una media de 143.5
centímetros y una desviación estándar de
alrededor de 7.1 centímetros desviación
estándar es igual a 7.1 centímetros cuál
es la probabilidad de que un alumno de
quinto año seleccionado lasarte en una
estatura mayor de 157 puntos 7
centímetros dibujemos la distribución
como lo hemos hecho en un montón de
problemas previos sólo hay una pregunta
si es que podemos marcar libre
esta distribución digamos que esta es
nuestra distribución y aquí tenemos la
media la cual nos es dada la media tiene
un valor de 143.5 centímetros nos están
pidiendo que tenga una estatura mayor de
157 puntos 7 centímetros eso es por
arriba de la media tomemos una
desviación estándar por arriba de la
media la desviación estándar es 7.1
entonces 143.5 7.1 es tanto como 150
puntos 6 eso es una desviación estándar
vamos a tomar otra desviación estándar
otra desviación estándar es 150 puntos
67 punto uno es 157.7 que coincide
exactamente con el valor que nos están
pidiendo no están pidiendo cual la
probabilidad de que tenga una estatura
mayor a 150 y 7.7 la cual corresponde al
área de esta región la cual corresponde
a dos desviaciones estándar a partir de
la media o dos desviaciones estándar por
arriba de la media en tomar en cuenta
esta cola del lado izquierdo podemos
aplicar la regla empírica la regla
empírica
si tomamos desviaciones estándar hacia
la izquierda aquí tenemos una aquí
tenemos dos desviaciones estándar
sabemos que el área de toda esta región
déjame agarra auto color sabemos que
esta área es el área que se encuentra
dentro de dos desviaciones estándar la
regla empírica nos dice o mejor la regla
del 68 95 99.7 nos dice que esta área
dado que está dentro de dos desviaciones
estándar es 95% o punto 95 es decir 95%
del área bajo la curva distribución
normal lo cual implica que lo que queda
es el área de esta cola que nos interesa
y esta otra cola es la diferencia es 5%
entonces estas dos combinadas tienen que
ser 5 % y son simétricas ya hemos hecho
esto antes de hecho es un poco
redundante a partir de otros problemas
que hemos hecho pero si estas combinadas
suman 5% entonces cada una de estas es
igual a 2.5 por ciento entonces
respondiendo a la pregunta cual la
probabilidad de que un alumno de quinto
año seleccionado a lanzarte
estatura mayor de 157 puntos 7
centímetros es el área de esta región en
verde lo voy a hacer de otro color vamos
a ponerlo en magenta es esta área la
cual hemos calculado que es 2.5 por
ciento entonces hay 2.5 por ciento de
probabilidad de seleccionar un alumno al
azar de quinto año cuya estatura es
mayor de 157 puntos 7 centímetros
suponiendo esta media esta desviación
estándar y una distribución
aproximadamente normal